Again, that should not have been too hard. The answer is, of course, a bug in the compiler.
We can check all of these possible causes by the changes they have.
No me would have some effect--well, you wouldn't be able to listen to this course right now.
Richard Stallman--no Richard Stallman would have a huge impact.
The GNU project is the source for so much great open source software out there.
We would have a very different role. Oxygen is of more important.
I can't even start to begin to imagine how our world would look like, and of all these courses,
fixing a bug in the compiler has by far the smallest set of assumption and also the smallest effect
because apart from fixing the bug and apart from fixing the crash, nothing else changes
and therefore, this is the actual cause.